you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some sit-down tending bar but in walks
someone that's pretty hard not to
recognize earthworm jim strange thing
about it is that they wasn't quite look
at himself which for someone that looks
like us look Jim is really something was
wearing as usual simply was he was one
the muscle suit but he was wearing a
normal suit over it like a suit you went
to go to work suit coat tie the whole
thing and he had this look of extreme
sadness on his face and go on make him a
drink I'll say boy Jim won the world
face and lack of nose I said well that's
to do with the release of the new birth
work Jim cake
there isn't a new birth one Jim game and
he says exactly I was a big hit in the
nineties he said the most original thing
out there nobody made a game like me
there wasn't even a character I played I
even made a sequel
Earthworm Jim - just as big as the first
one oh yeah I remember that everything
was so strange and so real and out there
so much fun so uh so what happened
I'll tell you what happened Nintendo 64
happened
I mean a lot of good games came up Tendo
sixty-four like Mario Kart games
Goldeneye was wonderful he said yeah but
they gave me you know the treatment so
what's the treatment
to me and he said you know the treatment
the sixty-four treatment
Alain Mason yeah 3d platforming so many
games were destroyed by that format I
took away the creativity and a genius
game designed and throw it away for
giant walls that had no detail on them
and moving blocks I have to try a
million times to jump on top of before
you can actually land on it and looking
at the back of your main character's
head for hours and hours an answer
that's a shame but you know there was
some good 3d platformer games Tomb
Raider was fantastic again golden ollie
racism yeah
how about all the creativity how about
all the cool characters how about the
fact that earth one Jim was always a
side-scrolling game and always meant to
be a side-scrolling game and I'll say
creativity in that game a said why will
than a creativity you have jolly and
bland walls you can look at or blocks
you can you walk on top off and I'll say
well that sounds strange like they
didn't try to put in any creative
characters and said oh they did they
just failed horribly and all sorts of
brilliant ideas like uh the four legged
cat that was a jaw-dropper or how about
the woman with the extra finger I really
got on selling off the aisles and also
well that's a shame about the characters
but then again button Jim had such great
settings
oh yeah they had a lot of great ones for
the 64 game too like the Red Room the
green room
and the red and green well-muscled chase
that's tough but you know it was the 60
full at the time everyone was excited
for those 3d worlds and what you could
do with them I mean at least the
graphics were better oh yeah yeah I'll
tell you the 2d animation Mar game looks
so piss-poor compared to what the 64 was
doing I mean who needs hand-drawn
creativity when everybody can look like
goddamn c-3po it was a total disaster
nobody liked it after that the TV show
was canceled nobody was reading the
comics it was just a total explosion
what you do with yourself as well turned
a prick
awesome you tent the crap give me like
the drunk no crack on the sidewalk
another one remember we can crawl into
anything I just snuck in there and I
waited until the dirt would consume me
that's it your birth one how can the
dirt consume you they said yeah that's
what drew my attention to don't decide
it if you can't beat the establishment
you might as well join them so I won't
wear any lonely world with no
self-esteem would go marketing for
presidential campaigns not so really
which one a sense does it matter and I
said I guess not and I looked at Munson
so no more the goofiness no more there's
a meanness awarding overtopped stuff
that doesn't make any sense he says I'm
in politics I get nothing but that now
but I don't you mean and no more the
surreal humor they used to make me so
enjoyable
well she does tell you man you had a
good run suddenly his cell phone rang
and he picked it up I can't quite make
it out but I guess the person was asking
if
the presidential candidate whoever was
shall wear tie that was covered in
eyeballs and Jim just gave a good look
at his phone see how his phone didn't
really matter viewers look at it but
nonetheless gave the phone a good look
and said who's in charge of marketing
around here you tell him to wear the
eyeball tie as well as the tongue hat
I've never been wrong before guys seem
to agree and hung up the phone Jim
looked at me you gave me a little wink
they walked out the door as long as you
can make life just a little bit surreal
things seem to work out in the end
except for Jim he got fired I mean I
won't tie in a tongue hat I was just
insane but you know what like thousands
plan the whole time instead of like
before where he comes in crazy and then
has to merge with the rational world
maybe you can take the rational world
and add just a little bit of craziness
just to make the world a little bit more
sorry
and anyway Mitt Romney's campaign could
get any worse ooh he's he'll wall
street's things as a bartender you see a
wall strange things at the pizza palace
so I'll see a lot of strange things as a
bartender and the bits of palace and
then ain't no lie